ein amazon logistikcenter in deutschland
heimlich gefilmt hier wird so greenpeace
neue ware vernichtet amazon erntete ein
shitstorm
diese vernichtung von neuware die
vernichtung von ressourcen ist einfach
nicht mehr tragbar zeit die klimakrise
die kampagne stellt den online-riesen an
den pranger und schärft das bewusstsein
gegen verschwendung der jedem textil wir
stecken ja wertvolle ressourcen
bis zu 3.000 verschiedenen chemikalien
in berührung bringt der produktion
verbraucht extrem viel wasser wenn im
normalen weißen baumwoll shirt so das
einfachste was man herstellen kann
jemand schon so von 2700 liter wasser
aus das ist so viel mehr menschen zwar
erklärt trinkt das problem beim
online-handel es wird viel
zurückgeschickt nicht immer lohnt sich
die aufarbeitung
20 millionen artikel werden jedes jahr
entsorgt
er hat das ausgerechnet logistiker
bionaz decker aber ist der onlinehandel
überhaupt das größte problem
allein aufgrund der handelsvolumina ist
der stationären handel noch deutlich
größer als der online handel es kommt zu
weniger retouren also zurück gaben im
handel aber eher für die silberbestände
die enorm sind
die branche wuchs rasant werden
deutschland lebt gab vor corona im
schnitt mehr als 900 euro im jahr für
bekleidung aus ein marktvolumen von 76
milliarden euro der hauptteil preiswerte
fast fashion die größten zuwächse waren
die
die preisgünstig modern wohnen haben sie
sportlich zu klein für kleines geld ist
natürlich schon
corona traf den handel als schock drei
lockdown sda zwischen rabattschlachten
wohin mit der bereits bestellten ware
der handel blieb auf bergen von kleidung
sitzen wintersachen zum beispiel die
sich im sommer nicht verkaufen lassen es
geht um gewaltige mengen
[Musik]
800 millionen touristen wie neu
produziert wurden die nicht verkauft
wurden und das ist die sogenannte korona
kollektion das heißt dass mit den jetzt
passiert ist komplett unklar viele
händler haben die wirklich einfach
angegeben dass sie vernichten wollen
massenhaft neue ware zur vernichtung in
deutschland wäre das gar nicht erlaubt
diese vornehmen das ist nicht passiert
dass tatsächlich neue machen die man
verkaufen kann da können wir keinen fall
und natürlich nicht alle 20.000
auch der online riese amazon sieht sich
zu unrecht an den pranger gestellt
tatsächlich liegt die zahl der von
amazon verkauften und versandten
produkte die entsorgt werden müssen im
promillebereich und wir arbeiten
intensiv daran die zahl immer weiter zu
reduzieren
arabischen spenden einlagern recyceln
für vieles beauftragten die händler
weitere firmen zwischenhändler und
entsorger so ist schwer nachvollziehbar
was mit welchen textilien geschieht
wenn sie jetzt eine studie machen über
die entsorgung im stationären haben oder
die entsorgung von den über beständig
sich jetzt in der kommune zeit aufgetan
haben dann werden sie da keine
teilnehmer bekommen da wird einfach
keiner mitmachen weil darüber nicht
gesprochen werden soll im letzten jahre
deutschland seine gesetze verschärft die
vernichtung neuwertige ware ist nun
offiziell verboten vor allem aber soll
das gesetz für mehr transparenz sorgen
frage an den wissenschaftler wird das
klappen man muss dazu sagen dass dieses
gesetz nur hersteller und händler
erfasst diese ganzen mittels männer also
plattformen die entsorgungsunternehmen
da wurde so eine flanke offen gelassen
die in der praxis dazu führen würde dass
dieses gesetz an vielen stellen
zahnloser tiger bleiben wird was also
hilft brauchen wir wirklich immer mehr
klamotten in deutschland hat jede person
im schnitt 95 kleidungsstücke jedes
fünfte davon wird nie getragen
der beste klimaschutz ist alltags
aktivismus wächst neu kaufen egal ob
sich elektronik geräte handelt oder um
bücher oder eben auch kleidungsstücke
leyen bieten teil tauschen die modelle
gibt es und die müssen jetzt halt auch
staatlich unterstützt werden das problem
allerdings noch immer ist shoppen gehen
in deutschland eines der beliebtesten
hobbys